no wait welcome to see the plain KS from
Germany it seems whoa
that's aggressive yeah of course that's
a playable play one set out not going to
win quickly but you get your pieces out
call a system to put unusual what is
white trying to do take on SIF take on
c5 trying to keep the pawn maybe I
didn't really take that so it's so
serious this idea but maybe he tries to
do it yes really play before yes oh my
god and you have to go back but I'm
threatening all kinds of stuff now 94
196 so let's go
it's really hard to believe that this
should work so 95 simply or can also
play a five yeah maybe
be five night before probably castles
long a four complete craziness it could
work I mean it doesn't look maybe it
looks it looks strange but it could work
I don't see why why not he's threatening
a three then no wonder that that was too
crazy even for this person so what to do
here yeah this is the usual move let's
do it
oh I'm actually hanging you seven I
didn't see that
anyway anyway ninety-seven B should be
297 I don't even know if it was helpful
thank you also take t5 here just
conservative flame or move this I don't
know
hmm fatigue here Luke shakes a form
threatens Queen a5 I don't know if
that's good him can also move the bishop
back Bishop g7 97 and the King Musa
that's completely crazy but it's good
huh that must be good actually
oh wait 97 and and Knight g5 h 6 9 f 7 i
think he's and he has this stuff oh my
god
he's killing me with this with this with
this crazy stuff that's cool yeah that's
actually cool I mean okay I'm Knight
takes d5 and and a four probably was
just good for me but 95 now he's
threatening Knight f7 rook takes knight
c6 my queen is not protected maybe I can
play some Bishop before ii said somehow
help doesn't know he will window he were
win the queen yeah yeah oh god if i
check and go King g7 Queen age seven
King to f6 to set I mean if I check and
h5 he's got 96 I can move the King Llane
actually
I know he takes on their seven of course
and then not just six so okay after this
so this was my intention queen age seven
king of six that's completely bonkers I
can take it I take it seven at the end
okay but if I do this night f7 rook F
796 Jay King g7 Queen takes the age at
the end and there are immediate threat
so I have to do it maybe he has some
checkmate also yeah it looks looks like
there should be one I can I have five
first or 94 I'd take on c3 is probably
enough even though it doesn't look like
an immediate win man maybe it is an
immediate red no I should have just
played the normal yeah yeah I saw it
just a little bit too late okay rook
takes Queen f7 am i mated I have to take
anyway
check
kg4 check and then made f3 maid or
something
my king position is so bad he can even
play some rubbish move and sir would win
them I cannot escape that ya like like
this one time morning I can still not
escape
but this position is so terrible when
I'm still existing I had a move we had
it made already Queen age six was made
but I still think it's it's going to be
lost him
what is he doing here okay
and that's that's what said yeah yeah I
couldn't I couldn't I couldn't prevent
it anyway checkmate there was this was
so utterly made that could do anything
even against this this this this thing
yeah so that didn't work him I just I'd
have to play the other liner just take
here and play it for which is all it
seems also not good yeah that was that
was really really weird yeah probably a
five wasn't greater that that I mean
objectively speaking I don't think this
is any good I mean that's pretty clear
but in the game it worked out for him
quite well yeah I probably I should
start with Knights each night here
something something like that is
probably okay that's better I just
didn't believe in in before at all but
yeah it seemed to not be complete
completely terrible b6 was better here
a5 a5 doesn't work what I mentioned is
that long castles this work is
that and I have no square for the night
so that was completely wrong approach
and 95 seems to be not that great night
age five is a very strange move what the
engine just we'll just had the pawn that
makes sense yeah this this is then no
good I have to take on d5 though I I
mean I I saw that that tactic just a bit
too late now night f7 is system possible
to impossible to present and yet it's
made
check check check check
now you had yet this easy mate check
checkmate
and that's it no but yeah anyway that
was a bit too creative by me thanks for
watching